all right let's talk about this big news  man The Daily Mail reports FBI deep  State team of 80 people regularly handed  Twitter lists of people to ban including  actor Billy Baldwin and satire accounts  new Trove of musk's Twitter files reveal  Matt Tybee posted a new Trove of Twitter  documents on Friday they show emails  from FBI officials requesting bans on  Twitter users how dare they go after  Billy Baldwin that's the most shocking  thing of all so here's here's one of the  emails it's uh from what from fbi.gov  Twitter folks please see below list of  Twitter accounts which we believe are  violating your terms of service by  disseminating false information about  the time place or manner of the upcoming  election let us know if you decide to  take any action against these accounts  based on your your uh our Tipper to you  also let us know if we need to issue a  preservation letter as we intend to  serve legal process for these accounts  thanks for your consideration